This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 1933, a group of architects boarded a ship called the SS Patrice II and set sail from Marseille, France toward Athens, Greece. On board were several of the world's most famous modernist architects and artists, Erno Goldfinger, Le Corbusier, of our alto, and dozens of others representing more than 15 countries. There was a silent film made of the voyage that shows grainy shots of the architects on deck of the ship in short-sleeved white shirts and sunglasses, cigarettes in their mouths their hair blowing gently in the breeze as they listen to lectures.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1933年，一群建筑师登上了一艘名为“帕特里亚二号”的轮船，从法国马赛起航，驶向希腊雅典。船上有几位世界上最著名的现代主义建筑师和艺术家，如埃尔诺·戈德芬格、勒·柯布西耶、奥古斯特·佩雷等等，还有来自15个以上的国家的数十位代表。当时有人为这次航行拍摄了一部无声电影，画面中隐约可见建筑师们身着短袖白衬衫、戴着太阳镜站在船甲板上的场景，他们嘴里叼着香烟，头发在微风中轻轻飘扬，正聚精会神地听着讲座。
One of the architects wrote in his journal, we eat and drink copiously, and we're all half naked. The architects were on the ship for the International Congress of Modern Architecture, commonly known by its French acronym CM. That's senior producer Katie Mangle, and I'm going to hand this story over to her now. So, yeah, the architects were on this boat trip for a CM meeting, but more specifically, they were there to talk about how to plan a better city. The members of CN thought that cities were too congested, too noisy and polluted and chaotic, and they thought that some of these problems could be solved by separating out the functions of a
其中一位建筑师在他的日记中写道，我们大吃大喝，而且几乎赤身裸体。建筑师们登上这艘船是为了参加“国际现代建筑协会”，这个组织通常以其法语缩写CIAM为人所知。那是高级制作人凯蒂·明格尔，现在我要把这个故事交由她来讲。所以，是的，建筑师们是为了参加CIAM的会议而进行这次乘船之旅的，但更具体地说，他们是为了探讨如何规划更好的城市。CIAM的成员认为城市过于拥挤、嘈杂、污染严重且混乱，他们认为其中一些问题可以通过将城市的各项功能划分为不同的区域来解决。
city into distinct zones. So, separate everything, housing, working, recreation, traffic, separate all the kinds of traffic. So pedestrians, the cyclists, cars, the trains, it would mean the end of congestion. That's Zeph Hamel. I'm Zeph Hamel and I'm a planner. Hamel spent a bunch of years working for the City of Amsterdam as the head of the Urban Planning Department. And now he teaches at the University of Amsterdam. And yeah, I love cities. The idea of separation of functions wasn't brand new. But Hamel says the architects from CM wanted to take it really far.
因此，将一切都隔离开来：居住、工作、娱乐、交通，将各种交通方式隔离开来——行人、骑自行车的人、汽车、火车，这将意味着交通拥堵的终结。那是泽夫·哈梅尔。我是泽夫·哈梅尔，我是一名规划师。哈梅尔曾在阿姆斯特丹市政府担任城市规划部门负责人多年。现在他在阿姆斯特丹大学任教。是的，我热爱城市。功能分区的理念并非全新发明。但哈梅尔表示，CIAM的建筑师们希望将这一理念推向极致。
The living spaces would be in high-rise apartments so that the ground level was open for recreation and collective spaces. Live in the sky, play on the ground. In fact, cars would drive on elevated roads so that pedestrians could have the ground all to themselves. There would also be separate zones for industry and shopping. Where old European cities were winding, cluttered and polluted,
居住空间将设在高层公寓中，以便地面空间能够腾出来用于娱乐和集体活动。生活在云端，玩耍在地面。事实上，汽车将在高架道路上行驶，这样行人就可以独享地面。此外，工业区和购物区也将实行分区规划。如果说欧洲的旧城市是曲折、杂乱和受污染的，
these new cities would be linear, open and clean. Everything in its proper place. It should be a kind of smooth, nice machine where you're very comfortable. Modernists also saw this new kind of city as more egalitarian. They wanted to get rid of slums and create beautiful housing that everyone could afford. It was a beautiful image, a new image, a new alternative for living in cities. That's the American city planner Oscar Newman in a BBC documentary called The Writing on the Wall. Put the people up, give them a view.
那么这些新城市将是线性、开阔和清洁的。一切各得其所。它应该像一台流畅、美观的机器，让你感到非常舒适。现代主义者还将这种新型城市视为更加平等的象征。他们希望消除贫民窟，创造每个人都能负担得起的美丽住房。那是一个美丽的意象，一个新的意象，一个城市生活的新替代方案。美国城市规划师奥斯卡·纽曼在BBC一部名为《墙上的字》的纪录片中这样说道：把人们送上去，给他们视野。
The view happens to be the other buildings, but give them a view, give them space down below, free the grounds. It was a great image. But in the 1930s, that's all it was, a great image, because the world was in an economic depression. There was not much to do in the 1930s, because it was the crisis. There was not much to do in the 1930s because it was the crisis.
视野碰巧是其他的建筑，但给他们视野，给他们下方的空间，解放地面。这是一个极好的愿景。但在20世纪30年代，它也仅仅是一个美好的愿景，因为当时世界正处于经济大萧条之中。在20世纪30年代没什么事可做，因为那是一场危机。在20世纪30年代没什么事可做，因为那是一场危机。
There was no building anymore. And then we got the Second World War. It sounds cynical, but in fact, they were rather lucky that so many cities were destroyed in the Second World War. And we even found documents that they almost celebrated at this destruction. So there was a lot of work to do in 1945. And they were really excited.
建筑工程已经停滞不全。然后我们迎来了第二次世界大战。这听起来可能很冷血，但事实上，他们反倒觉得挺幸运，因为在二战中有那么多城市被摧毁。我们甚至找到了文件，显示他们几乎在为这种破坏而庆祝。因此，在1945年有大量的工作要做。他们感到非常兴奋。
But it wasn't just that the architects had a lot of work. It was an opportunity to start over, to build cities the right way, from the ground up. Yes, and that was all, that was their idea from the start. So tear everything down. Let's start again. The CM Architect seized this opportunity. The famous Swiss architect and CM member, Le Corbusier, published a book called Le Le Charte d'Atene.
但这不仅意味着建筑师们有很多工作要做。这也是一个重新开始的机会，一个从头开始、以正确方式建设城市的机会。是的，这就是全部，这从一开始就是他们的想法。所以，拆除一切。让我们重新开始。CIAM的建筑师们抓住了这个机会。著名的瑞士建筑师、CIAM成员勒·柯布西耶出版了一本名为《雅典宪章》的书。
Or in English, the Athens Charter. The book outlined exactly how to build new cities in the way the architects from CM had talked about on the boat. And it became a bestseller. Le Corbusier traveled the world talking about these modern ideas for city building. And governments liked what they saw, mostly because of the price tag. What Siam proposed was, in fact, very cheap building. Concrete, the modernist building material of choice was inexpensive.
或者用英文来说，The Athens Charter。这本书准确地概述了如何按照CIAM建筑师在船上讨论的方式来建造新城市。它成了一本畅销书。勒·柯布西耶环游世界，宣讲这些关于城市建设的现代理念。各国政府对他们所看到的成果很满意，主要原因是造价低廉。CIAM所提议的实际上是非常廉价的建筑。混凝土作为现代主义建筑首选的材料，价格并不昂贵。
And building identical apartments in high-rises was cheaper and required less land than building standalone homes. And that was what all the governments needed after the Second World War, because whole Europe was poor. And so, after World War II, in cities all over Europe, buildings and housing developments were rebuilt with CM principles in mind. Almost everything. Here in Europe, almost everything. We built a lot of modernist style apartment buildings here in the US too. But these building projects
而且在高层建筑中建造相同的公寓，比建造独栋住宅更便宜，也需要更少的土地。这正是二战后所有政府所需要的，因为整个欧洲都贫穷不堪。因此，二战后，欧洲各地的城市在重建时都将CIAM的原则铭记在心。几乎所有地方。在欧洲，几乎所有地方都是如此。我们在美国也建造了大量现代主义风格的公寓楼。但这些建筑项目
in post-war Europe and the United States weren't usually pure encapsulations of CM and Le Corbusier's plans. Most places took some ideas and left others. But the city planners of Amsterdam and the Netherlands wanted to go further. They wanted to build a new area right outside of Amsterdam. There would be a CM blueprint, a perfect encapsulation of these modernist principles. They would call this place the Belmer Mirror. So from the center of MSTEM, I think you could take the bike and within a half hour you
在战后的欧洲和美国，通常并不是CIAM和勒·柯布西耶计划的纯粹体现。大多数地方采纳了一些想法，而抛弃了另一些。但阿姆斯特丹和荷兰的城市规划者们想要走得更远。他们想在阿姆斯特丹郊外直接建造一片新区域。那里将有CIAM的蓝图，完美体现这些现代主义原则。他们将这个地方命名为拜尔默米尔。因此，从阿姆斯特丹市中心出发，我认为你可以骑自行车，在半小时内就能到达拜尔默米尔。
are in the Belmer Mirror. That's Dutch radio producer Chris Bayema. He co-reported this story with me and like a proper Dutchman, he wrote his bike out to do interviews many times at the Belmer Mirror. I always take my bike. So you'll hear him asking questions and occasionally speaking in Dutch. We can't even say that it's dry now, we'll just walk to that thing.
那是荷兰广播制作人克里斯·拜耶马。他和我共同采访报道了这个故事，就像一个地道的荷兰人一样，他多次骑着自行车去拜尔默米尔进行采访。我总是骑自行车。所以你会听到他提出问题，偶尔说荷兰语。我们甚至不能说现在地是干的，我们直接走到那个地方去吧。
The Belmer Mirror area covers about 6 square kilometers or 2.3 square miles. I think you can walk around for a day. It's really big. Today, the Bill Mermere is also an extremely diverse area. There's something like 150 nationalities represented there. We sheep all your cargo to Ghana. It says on the... The area has changed a lot from the original design. And it's had a bunch of different chapters over the years,
拜尔默米尔地区的面积约为6平方公里，即2.3平方公里。我想你可以在那里逛上一整天。它真的很大。如今，拜尔默米尔也是一个极其多元化的地区。那里代表着大约150个国籍。我们把你们所有的货物都运到加纳。上面写着……这个地区的现状与最初的设计相比已经发生了很大变化。多年来，它经历过许多不同的篇章，
including some really tragic ones. So let's start at the beginning. First can you introduce yourself to your eye and what you are? My name is Peter Brown. I'm an architect in Amsterdam and I've been along for a while. I've been educated in Delft University. It was very much in the functionalist, modernist tradition. That means that the big concrete blocks that was our paradise. When he was a young man, the brown was hired to help plan the Belmer Mirror. It would be a brand-new area right outside of Amsterdam for 100,000 middle-class residents. And it would technically be part of Amsterdam, but it would be built from scratch and designed to function almost as its own city.
其中还包括一些非常悲惨的篇章。那么，让我们从头说起。首先，你能向大家自我介绍一下你是谁，以及你以前是做什么的吗？我叫彼得·布朗。我是阿姆斯特丹的一名建筑师，我已经在这里工作很长时间了。我毕业于代尔夫特理工大学。当时非常推崇功能主义和现代主义传统。这意味着那些巨大的混凝土块就是我们的天堂。当他年轻时，布朗被聘请去协助规划拜尔默米尔。这将是阿姆斯特丹郊外的一个崭新区域，旨在容纳10万名中产阶级居民。从技术上讲，它将是阿姆斯特丹的一部分，但它将从零开始建造，并且被设计得几乎可以作为一个独立的城市来运作。
A city of the future, true to the tenets of modernism. The Belmer Mere, it's the apotheosis of all modernists thinking. I say the dream come true for you? Oh, definitely, yes. I was not even 30 years old, a bit more than 25. We are going to present the world with a new, far reaching,
一座未来的城市，忠于现代主义的信条。拜尔默米尔，它是所有现代主义思想的顶峰。我可以说这是梦想成真吗？哦，绝对是，是的。我当时还不到30岁，刚过25岁没多久。我们将向世界展示一个全新的、深远的、
idea that utopic, I started to understand this is going far, and this is really unusual. It was like a fever, my every day, every moment, in that direction. The Brown worked on a team with a bunch of other planners, and the head of the team was an architect named SIGFRIED NASSUTE. Yeah, SIGFRIED NASSUTE was really a idealistic person. And he believed that how we built in the 19th, 18th century wasn't good enough. We had to do it all over again and knew and bigger and better. This is Dan Decker.
具有乌托邦色彩的理念，我开始意识到这太超前了，而且真的非同寻常。这就像是一种狂热，我每天的每一刻都朝着那个方向努力。布朗与一团队其他的规划者共事，团队负责人是一位名叫齐格弗里德·纳苏特的建筑师。是的，齐格弗里德·纳苏特确实是一个极具理想主义色彩的人。他坚信我们在19世纪、18世纪的建造方式还不够好。我们必须全部推倒重来，打造全新的、更宏大、更好的东西。这是丹·德克尔。
I'm a writer and I wrote a book about the Belmer. The Belmer is just a shorter way of saying the Belmer mirror. You'll hear people use it a lot. Anyway, Dan says there was never any question that the Belmer would be made up of tall, concrete housing towers. But the planners did choose to arrange them in a sort of unique shape.
我是一名作家，我写了一本关于拜尔默的书。“拜尔默”（Bijlmer）是“拜尔默米尔”（Bijlmermeer）的简称。你会经常听到人们这样用。不管怎样，丹说，关于拜尔默是否将由高大的混凝土住宅楼组成，从来没有任何疑问。但规划者确实选择以一种独特的方式来排列它们。
Which was a shape of a honing, blah, blah, blah, blah, what's how you say, yeah, blah. I have to search the words, because I have to. Yeah, we have to search the words honing, blah, blah, blah, blah, what's how you say? Yeah, blah. I have to search the words, because I have to. Yeah, we have to search the words. Honing that. Honeycomb? Honeycomb, yeah. If the buildings were laid out in the hexagonal grid of a honeycomb, they would allow each apartment
也就是蜂窝的形状，啦啦啦啦，你怎么说来着，对，啦。我得想想那个词，因为我必须……对，我们得想想那个词，蜂窝，啦啦啦啦，你怎么说来着？对，啦。我得想想那个词，因为我必须……对，我们得想想那个词。那个是蜂窝？蜂窝，对。如果这些建筑物按照蜂窝的六边形网格排列，它们将使每间公寓
to get a good amount of sun per day. The modernists were crazy about sunlight. That was a huge part of their doctrine. You were doing better than your predecessors. If you could bring more sun to all these dwellings. The apartments at the Belmer were meant for the middle class, and no apartment was designed to be better than another. The image of man behind this Belmermier was egalitarian. The basic idea behind it was that every man is equal to his neighbor. The modernist idea to keep all of the functions of a city separate was also strictly followed at the Belmer.
每天都能获得充足的阳光。现代主义者对阳光有着狂热的喜爱。那是他们信条中极其重要的一部分。如果你能让所有这些住宅都享受到更多的阳光，你就比你的前辈做得更好。拜尔默的公寓是为中产阶级设计的，没有哪套公寓被设计得比另一套更好。这个拜尔默米尔背后的理想人设是平等的。其背后的基本思想是，每个人与他的邻居都是平等的。现代主义将城市的所有功能分开保持独立的理念，在拜尔默也得到了严格的遵循。
The housing would be up in the sky in towers, while the ground would be kept open for the people to congregate in green spaces and indoor collective areas. The idea being, people would discuss politics there, philosophy, help each other grow in life, make better people. At one point, Pida Brown proposed apartments be built on the ground level of the building,
住宅将建在高空的高层建筑中，而地面则保持开阔，供人们在绿地和室内公共区域聚集。其理念是，人们将在那里讨论政治、哲学，在生活中互相帮助共同成长，成为更好的人。有一次，彼得·布朗建议在建筑的地面层建造公寓，
and NASA was completely horrified and appalled, saying, Pete Abround proposed apartments be built on the ground level of the building, and Nassoud was completely horrified and appalled, saying, The ground is for everyone. The earth should not be inhabited by private people. The Browns has any suggestion to stray from the original principles of modernism was completely shut down by Nassoud. He would say, no, stop. We're not going this direction. We'll stay in the party line.
而纳苏特对此感到非常震惊和骇然，他说：彼得·布朗建议在建筑的地面层建造公寓，而纳苏特对此感到非常震惊和骇然，他说：地面属于所有人。地球不应该由私人占据。布朗任何想要偏离现代主义最初原则的建议都被纳苏特完全否决了。他会说，不，停下。我们不往这个方向走。我们要紧跟党的路线。
It was like a religion. And any, any subversive element was potentially a big danger to the House of Cards. OK, but you also were what we call, in the Netherlands, a Balmer believer. And you actually moved to a flat in 69. I was so much involved in the modern movement, in modernism.
这就像是一种宗教。任何颠覆性的元素都可能对这座纸牌屋构成巨大的危险。好的，但你也是我们在荷兰所说的“拜尔默信徒”。你实际上在1969年搬进了一套公寓。我太投入于现代主义运动了。
It was no doubt that I would like to live in the middle of it. De Brown was not the only person who wanted to live in the middle of it. Debron was not the only person who wanted to live in the middle of it. Advertisements depicted a paradise, modern apartment towers surrounded by lush, green grass and trees. It's comparable with living in Central Park. It's even going to be better than Central Park. Of course, people wanted in. Each building was managed by a different housing association and there were waiting lists and interviews to be accepted as a tenant. The Brown and his wife moved in in 1969.
毫无疑问，我很想住在它的正中央。德布朗并不是唯一一个想住在它正中央的人。德布朗并不是唯一一个想住在它正中央的人。广告描绘了一个天堂般的景象，四周环绕着郁郁葱葱的绿草和树木的现代公寓大楼。这堪比住在中央公园。甚至会比中央公园还要好。当然，人们都想搬进去。每栋建筑都由不同的房屋协会管理，有排队名单和面试，以被接受为租户。德布朗和他的妻子于1969年搬了进去。
I lived on the ninth floor, three bedrooms and a living room and kitchen, a beautiful bathroom. I had a balcony of close to two meters white and 12 meters long. It was a paradise of a balcony. The brown had always lived in small apartments in noisy cities. Now he was on the ninth floor up in the clouds, tons of light, and he loved it. He talks about his first year at the Belmer, like it was a religious experience. Very much, and every day, saintly feeling. You know, all this daily hostility of a city, noise, wasn't the case. There was a cool and silent air,
我住在九楼，有三个卧室、一个客厅和一个厨房，还有一个漂亮的浴室。我有一个近两米宽、十二米长的阳台。那简直是一个阳台中的天堂。德布朗一直住在嘈杂城市的狭小公寓里。现在他身处九楼云端，拥有充足的光线，他非常喜欢这里。他谈起他在拜尔默的第一年，感觉就像经历了一场宗教洗礼。非常深刻，每一天都有神圣的感觉。你知道，城市中所有那些日常的敌意、噪音，都不复存在了。空气凉爽而宁静，
a life that brought you deeper into yourself, maybe. But there were also pretty immediate problems. A metro was supposed to connect the Belmer with Amsterdam, but the construction was delayed. For a while there was only one road out to the area, and it was dirt. The designers had also planned for shops to come to the Belmer Mirror, but those didn't come right away either. There was nowhere to buy groceries if you didn't have a car or didn't want to ride your bike 30 minutes to Amsterdam. That came a this kind of driving van every Friday or maybe twice in a week to sell a bottle of milk. It was
也许是一种能带你深入内心的生活。但也存在一些相当迫克不容缓的问题。一条地铁本应将拜尔默与阿姆斯特丹连接起来，但建设工作被延误了。有一段时间，通往该地区的只有一条土路。设计者还计划在拜尔默米尔开设商店，但这些也没有马上兑现。如果你没有车，或者不想骑自行车花30分钟去阿姆斯特丹，那就没地方买杂货。每周五或者一周两次会有一种开着货车来卖牛奶的人。那真是
twice in a week to sell a bottle of milk. It was very, very primitive. Eventually the roads did come and true to the modernist idea of separation of functions, they were elevated above the ground, sort of weaving in and out of the high rises. I remember you could drive with your car and then have this spectacular view of the Belmer, seeing all those high rises around you and then driving 70, 80 kilometers an hour through this city scape. Wow, that was amazing. That's Jeff Hamill again who you heard at the beginning and he says yeah it was amazing but it was also disorienting. It was always problematic to find your way. Where am I? Which flat building is this? Where am I going? You could not find the center. You couldn't find the center because there was no
一周两次来卖一瓶牛奶。这非常非常原始。最终道路还是修通了，并且忠实于现代主义的功能分区理念，它们被高架于地面之上，在各个高层建筑之间穿梭。我还记得你可以开车兜风，然后欣赏到拜尔默壮丽的景色，看到周围所有的高层建筑，然后以每小时70、80公里的速度穿过这个城市景观。哇，那太棒了。那是杰夫·哈梅尔，你在开头听过他，他说，是的，这很棒，但这也让人迷失方向。找路总是很麻烦。我在哪？这是哪栋公寓楼？我要去哪？你找不到中心。你找不到中心，因为没有
city center, no town square, just identical concrete buildings, one after another, after another. just identical concrete buildings, one after another, after another. Visitors were constantly getting lost, and they couldn't just pull over and ask for directions. No one would walk on that high level, so you would never encounter someone that was no way to ask, how can I get to this or this address? And on the ground level, the promised green space didn't come right away either. Green takes time to grow. And the brown says in the beginning, the landscape was like a desert. Below in the desert, you would also not encode or uncode or someone,
市中心，没有城镇广场，只有一栋又一栋、千篇一律的混凝土建筑。只有一栋又一栋、千篇一律的混凝土建筑。访客们经常迷路，而且他们不能随便把车停在路边问路。没有人会走在高架层上，所以你永远不会遇到任何人，根本没法问：我该怎么去这个或那个地址？而在地面层，承诺的绿化空间也没有马上实现。绿化需要时间生长。布朗说，一开始，这里的景观就像一片沙漠。在下面的沙漠里，你也同样遇不到任何人，
because who would walk through the desert? But I liked it. My wife liked it because she was with me, and we all young and there is a state of pioneering that many people like. What we are saying to the designing team because you live there. I would tell my superiors these planners like Nusset, it isn't working and he would say, this is you have to wait. This is because it's not finished yet. And so the brown waited. Other residents were not as patient. I remember this kind of old elderly couple
因为谁会穿过沙漠呢？但我很喜欢。我妻子也很喜欢，因为她和我在一起，我们都很年轻，有一种很多人都会喜欢的拓荒精神。我们对设计团队说的是因为你住在那里。我会告诉我的上司，像纳苏特这样的规划师，这行不通，而他会说，你得等等。这是因为还没完工。于是布朗等了下来。其他居民可没有那么有耐心。我记得有一对老年夫妇，
children left home, so they thought, okay, now we're going to this paradise that has been promised to us. And they were, after one year year completely disillusioned. The waiting list disappeared really fast. Desperate people that start screaming, where's the soapway, where are the shops? By the early 1970s, as the Belmer was being built, much of the world was already turning against the massive concrete apartment towers that modernists had pushed for in the 30s and 40s.
他们的孩子离家独立了，所以他们想，好吧，现在我们要去这个向我们承诺的天堂了。结果他们住了一年后彻底幻灭了。排队名单迅速缩短。绝望的人们开始尖叫：超级市场在哪里？商店在哪里？到了20世纪70年代初，随着拜尔默的建设，世界大部分地区已经开始反对现代主义者在30年代和40年代大力推崇的大型混凝土公寓大楼。
Nobody built these kind of structures at that time anymore. In America, in Silhouez, they were tearing them down. Today is Demolition Day at Crue et Igo. Door wrecking company will explode the supporting columns from an 11-story vacant high rise. from an 11-story vacant high rise. Prudigo in St. Louis had also been an experiment in the modernist principles of CM. It was different than the Belmer in that it was never meant to function
当时已经没有人再建造这种结构的建筑了。在美洲，在圣路易斯，他们正在将其拆除。今天是普鲁伊特-伊戈大楼的拆除日。拆迁公司将爆破一栋11层空置高层建筑的支撑柱。一栋11层空置高层建筑的支撑柱。圣路易斯的普鲁伊特-伊戈也是现代主义CIAM原则的一项实验。它与拜尔默的不同之处在于，它从未打算作为一个独立的城市来运作。
as a city unto itself. But it was similar, too, made up of 33 high rise towers surrounded by lots of green space. The architect had envisioned rivers of trees running between the buildings. Prudigo was completed in 1954, and just 15 years later it was so overrun with vacancies and drugs and violence that the city chose to tear it down. The current secretary of housing has decided that Prudhago wasn't back to a disastrous mistake.
但它也有相似之处，由33栋高层建筑组成，周围环绕着大片绿地。建筑师曾设想在建筑之间流淌着树木之河。普鲁伊特-伊戈于1954年建成，仅仅15年后，这里就充斥着空置房屋、毒品和暴力，以至于市政府选择将其拆除。现任住房部长已决定，普鲁伊特-伊戈不失为一个灾难性的错误。
That's the city planner Oscar Newman again. He theorized that it was all the common spaces at Prudhago that led to its downfall. Those rivers of trees, the architect had envisioned. They became sewers of glass and garbage, rather than rivers of trees. The insides of the building, the interior spaces were vandalized, the heating equipment torn apart, garbage, strewn everywhere, lights smashed, windows broken. Newman believed that if there was a lot of space
那是城市规划师奥斯卡·纽曼。他推测，正是普鲁伊特-伊戈的所有公共空间导致了它的衰落。建筑师所设想的那些树木之河，最终没有成为树木之河，反而变成了玻璃和垃圾的下水道。建筑内部、内部空间遭到破坏，供暖设备被拆毁，垃圾散落各处，灯光被砸碎，窗户被打破。纽曼认为，如果在建筑内部或周围有大量空间，
in or around a building that residents couldn't literally see from their own windows and watch over, that that space was vulnerable to crime. The net result of all this quality design was in fact the production of an environment of fear. In 1972, Oscar Newman visited the Belmer Mirror and he gave it essentially the same diagnosis. They can seize an empty common spaces, would become breeding grounds for crime. Even members of CM were turning against the Belmer.
而居民无法从自己的窗户字面意义上看到并照看这些空间，那么这些空间就容易受到犯罪的侵害。所有这些优质设计的最终结果，实际上是营造了一种恐惧的环境。1972年，奥斯卡·纽曼访问了拜尔默米尔，他基本上给出了同样的诊断：这些无人看管的空置公共空间将成为滋生犯罪的温床。甚至连CIAM的成员也开始反对拜尔默。
The famous Dutch architect and CM member Aldo Van Eyck went on national TV in the Netherlands and cried literal tears over what an awful concrete monstrosity the Belmer was. Yeah, yeah, yeah, cried. Yeah. Still more buildings went up. Massive concrete structures.
著名的荷兰建筑师、CIAM成员阿尔多·凡·艾克登上荷兰国家电视台，为拜尔默这座可怕的混凝土怪胎流下了字面意义上的眼泪。是的，是的，是的，哭了。是的。更多的建筑拔地而起。巨大的混凝土结构。
Around 400 apartments in each. First, there were a couple of buildings. Then there were four, then five, then six. There was no break, no stop. Seven, eight, nine buildings. You should have said, stop building more units because they'll be standing empty. And no have said stop building more units because they'll be standing empty and no one said that not even me. 10 15 buildings I'm gonna start
每栋大约有400套公寓。起初，有几栋建筑。然后是四栋、五栋、六栋。没有间断，没有停止。七栋、八栋、九栋建筑。你本该说，不要再建造更多单元了，因为它们会空置。然而没有人说不要再建造更多单元了，因为它们会空置，甚至连我也没有说。十栋、十五栋建筑，我要开始
counting in five because there are too many 20 buildings 25 30. These contractors had contracts for years and years of continuous building and they just did. And that was like oil on the fire. 31 buildings in all. 13,000 apartments arranged in hexagonal blocks. So that from above, the Belmer Mirror looked like a massive concrete sci-fi honing grad. Honing grad. Honey, come on. Yeah. Honing grad. In addition to all the buildings, there were also 13,000 storage spaces on the
按五的倍数来数，因为实在是太多了，二十栋、二十五栋、三十栋。这些承包商签下了长达数年连续施工的合同，他们就这样照做了。这就像是在火上浇油。总共31栋建筑。13,000套公寓，排列成六边形街区。从上方俯瞰，拜尔默米尔看起来就像一个巨大的混凝土科幻蜂窝网格。蜂窝网格。蜂蜜，来吧。对。蜂窝网格。除了所有的建筑，地面层还有13,000个储藏空间。
ground level. 31 parking garages, hundreds of elevators and staircases and common spaces, and 110 kilometers or 68 miles of indoor ground-level corridors. There was so much space, and not enough people to fill it up or watch over it. But there were still people who needed housing in the Netherlands. In fact, there were thousands of newly-arrived citizens who had traveled across the Atlantic Ocean from a tropical land in South America, and they needed a place to live. The story of the Belmer Mayor took so many twists and turns that we have to continue it next week. We'll have a preview of that episode right after this.
31个停车场，数百部电梯、楼梯和公共空间，以及110公里（即68英里）长的室内地面走廊。这里有太多的空间，却没有足够的人来填满它或照看它。但荷兰仍然有需要住房的人。事实上，有成千上万新到达的公民，他们跨越大西洋，来自南美洲的一个热带土地，他们需要一个居住的地方。拜尔默米尔的故事经历了如此多的转折，我们必须在下周继续讲述它。我们将在节目结束后为您提供该集的预览。
Next week on the show, the story of the Belmer Mayor continues. So here's a bunch of white guys. They decide to build this area. This Belmer Mayor area, people, it was the city of the future where living and working were physically separated and there would be a Subway and it would be great and it would be fantastic. Everybody would have spandex jackets. This was the idea. When the idea of the Belmer mere fails to live up to the reality, thousands of apartments said empty, and new people take them over. He said, we need houses, let's go get the houses. But the Belmer Meers newcomers aren't welcomed with open arms by all the old residents.
下周的节目中，拜尔默米尔的故事将继续。这里有一群白人男子。他们决定建造这个地区。这个拜尔默米尔地区，人们，它是未来的城市，居住和工作在物理上被隔离开来，这里会有地铁，它会很棒，它会非常奇妙。每个人都会穿上弹力夹克。这就是当时的构想。当拜尔默米尔的构想未能兑现现实时，成千上万的公寓空置了，新来的人接管了它们。他说，我们需要房子，让我们去弄房子吧。但拜尔默米尔的新来者并没有受到所有老居民的热烈欢迎。
So it was like inferno, really. The lifts didn't work, they threw the refuse over the balconies on either side of those blocks. It was like a ghetto. We were never the problem, we were the solution to the problem and we made something from it. And a tragic accident strikes the Belmer Mirror. They didn't let anybody go inside again. Everything, we lost everything.
所以这真的就像人间炼狱。电梯坏了，他们把垃圾从这些大楼两侧的阳台上扔下去。这就像一个贫民窟。我们从来都不是问题，我们是解决问题的方法，我们用它创造了一些东西。一场悲剧降临在拜尔默米尔。他们不再让任何人进去了。一切，我们失去了所有。
We lost everything. We lost everything. The only thing we get is our life. 99% Invisible was produced this week by our senior producer Katie Mingle and Chris Biema. Special thanks to Frank Wasenberg, Jean-Louis Cohen, and Boatat Yelama. Mixing Tech Production by Sharif Youssef, Music by Sean Riel. Delaney Hall is the senior editor. Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of staff includes Avery Trophman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Taren Mazza, and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of
我们失去了所有。我们失去了一切。我们得到的唯一东西就是我们的生命。本周的《99%隐形》由我们的高级制作人凯蒂·明格尔和克里斯·拜耶马制作。特别感谢弗兰克·瓦森伯格、让-路易·科恩和博塔特·耶拉马。混音技术制作由谢里夫·优素福负责，音乐由肖恩·里尔创作。德兰妮·霍尔担任高级编辑。库尔特·科尔斯特德担任数字总监。其他工作人员包括艾弗里·特罗夫曼、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、泰伦·马扎，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW电台的项目，
91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. We are part of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best most innovative shows in all a podcasting. We are supported by our coin carrying and sticker plastered listeners just like you. You can find 99% invisible and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI Orc, or on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But if you want to explore more of the Corbuciers modernist
并在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的“无线电街”制作。我们是PRX旗下播客网络Radiotopia的一部分，这是一个汇聚了播客界最优秀、最具创新性节目的集体。我们由像您一样随身携带硬币、贴满贴纸的听众资助。您可以在Facebook上找到《99%隐形》并加入关于节目的讨论。您也可以在推特上@我（Roman Mars）或节目（@99PIOrg），或者在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上找到我们。但如果您想探索更多柯布西耶关于房屋和城市的现代主义愿景，我们在本周发布了三篇文章的链接，它们真的非常非常棒。网址是99PI.org。Radiotopia。
vision for houses and cities, we have links to three articles come out this week and they're all really, really good. It's on our website, 99PI.org. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. From PRX. Radio Tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Radiotopia。来自PRX。来自PRX的Radiotopia。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。